Extra work,
five days,
zero experience and the world's best teachers.
We need to clear the mind.
Yeah.
Avoid Kasasa is take a chill pill like chilling.
I feel like I need to work on that pass punch.
I'm Tim Ferris,
best selling author and Human Guinea pig.
I'll show you how to make the impossible possible by bending the rules.
I'll find the world's best teachers and push myself to the edge to deconstruct,
decode,
and demystify some of the world's toughest challenges in record time if I can do
it.
So can you.
Hey guys,
this is Tim Ferriss Hirums having my tea and my,
what would you attempt if you knew you could not fail mug and for all of the
episodes of the Tim Ferriss experiment,
go four hour workweek.com forward slash TB and it's if all you are,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Dot Com forward slash TV where you will find not only all 13 episodes of the Tim
Ferriss experiment that you will find extended interviews really in depth
tutorials,
two to three hour in death dissections of some of these experts in their skills.
Tons of stuff that we just couldn't put into 21 or 22 minutes of television,
but for all of it behind the scene stuff,
all sorts of cool things with every type of variety.
Go to four hour workweek.com forward slash TB and thank you for watching.